-Nick, you've done
so many amazing characters
and impressions, in your career,
but also on our show.
I wanted to put your skills
to the test.
It is time
for "Guess the Impression."
♪♪
-♪ Guess the Impression ♪
♪ Guess the Impression ♪
-All right.
So we are each gonna try to do
as many impressions as we can.
We each have a list
of celebrities,
and you want to get
the other player to guess
as many as possible
before the timer runs out.
Since you're my guest, you'll go
first to make it easier on you.
-Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much, Jimmy.
That's so generous of you.
-I am a thoughtful --
I'm a thoughtful guy.
Well, all right.
You should see them on your
screen, the names will pop up.
-Yes.
-Whenever you're ready.
Set, go.
-Okay.
[ As Kermit ] I, uh,
like to have sex with a pig.
-Oh, uh, Ray Romano.
-No!
-Kermit the Frog,
Kermit the Frog!
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes, thank you.
-Sorry, Ray.
Sorry, Ray.
-[ As Vin Diesel ] Uh, uh, uh...
It's all about family.
I like to do karaoke
on Facebook.
I'm fast and furious.
-Oh, Vin Diesel.
[ Bell dings ]
-I've got milk --
I've got milk voice.
[ As Bane ] Oh, Jimmy,
I'm a Batman villain,
and I've been told
that I'm difficult to work with.
-Tom Hardy, Bane?
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes!
-[ Laughs ]
-[ As Clint Eastwood ]
Go -- Go ahead, make my day.
But make it --
-Oh, Clint Eastwood.
[ Bell dings ]
-Yeah.
But make it in one day,
because I am a hundred,
and I direct, and I only do
two takes of everything.
Uh, okay.
[ As Louis Armstrong ]
♪ And I think ♪
♪ "Is this
a racist impression?" ♪
-Louis Armstrong.
It is not.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Buzzer ]
That's your new song?
"Is This a Racist Impression?"
[ Both laugh ]
All right.
Ready, buddy? Here we go.
Start the clock.
-Okay.
-Oh, all right.
All right, look at you.
Wow.
Look, look at you, look at you.
What a great career --
What a great career you've had.
We said it all.
You've said it all.
-Is it Alec Baldwin?
Oh, you said --
It's Howard Stern.
Okay.
-Yes.
-Howard Stern.
-Okay.
Oh, God.
Um, my -- my buddy growing up,
Flip Flop, used to work at --
-Joe Biden?
-Yes.
[ Bell dings ]
Well, um...
Well, I'm very British, very --
-Hugh Grant.
-No, but I'm younger,
and I show up in things,
and I'm also a sleuth.
-Tom Holland.
-I'm a sleuth.
-Oh, it's a --
-I'm a superhero, as well.
-Yeah,
it's Benedict Cumberbatch.
-That is -- yes.
Thank you.
Oh, "Roobie roobie roo!"
-Uh, Scooby-Doo.
-Yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
Oh, gosh.
This one's a tough one.
Um, uh --
[ Buzzer ]
Let me see if I can get him.
-Yeah, I wanted
to see if I can get it.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, ready? He goes --
Yeah, um, could we -- uh...
Could we not --
Maybe could we not do this?
Yeah.
-It's not like Pesci.
You do a different thing
for Pesci.
-No, no, and I'm the dad,
and I'm a dad --
And I actually asked you nicely
not to go swimming in the lake.
-Jason Bateman?
[ Bell Dings ]
[ Both laugh ]
-All right, here we go.
This is the last round.
It's the last rhino,
as we call it here.
We're going to see how many
we can get together.
We're gonna take turns
doing impressions
and guessing
going back and forth.
All right. Ready?
-Okay.
-Uh, you're up first.
On your mark, 60 seconds.
Get set, go.
-[ Growling ]
-Oh, Chewbacca!
[ Bell dings ]
-Okay.
-Oh, um...
[ As Billie Eilish ] Um, uh, oh.
-Chalamet?
-Uh, no.
-Singer, Prince, Prince.
-Green hair, black hair.
-Okay, green hair.
Oh, oh, Billie Eilish.
-Yes, yeah.
[ Bell dings ]
Go.
-Yeah, you're gonna --
you're gonna --
[ Both laugh ]
-[ Mumbling ]
-Marlon Brando?
[ Bell dings ]
Oh, my -- Marlon Brando
had chewing tobacco.
All right, um, okay.
Uh...uh...
Wear a mask.
Why?
-Cuomo.
-No. But more like --
Yeah, yeah, that's what I said.
I didn't say that
we're gonna the thing.
The numbers
are gonna double, triple --
-Oh, not Bernie.
The numbers
are gonna double, triple.
[ Buzzer ]
Fauci, Fauci, Fauci, Fauci.
[ Bell dings ]
-All right, I've got Fauci and
Bateman I got to work on.
I've got Fauci
and Bateman to work on.
But we did well.
Four is good.
-Four is pretty good.
Can I give you
the next one I have?
-Yes.
-Hello! I'm not Mrs. Doubtfire.
[ Both laugh ]
-John Lovitz?
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
Hello!
No.
-Hello!
-It's the Queen.
-We're going to cut the turkey
and then --
It's Julia Child.
[ Bell dings ]
Hello!
It is the great Julia Child.
Oh, I do -- yeah.
-I'm single, and I'm available.
-There you go right there,
everybody.
Nick Kroll, everybody.
You can watch season 4
of his show, "Big Mouth,"
on Netflix this Friday,
December 4th.
He's happily married right now.
That is unbelievable!
Come on!